how are you i'm good your skin looks
very nice today kind of tan
well tan because i go out in the sun sun
is great why am i so white what is going
on well because i go in the sun you
don't go in the sun but also second is
that we both got eight hours of sleep
last night which you know good good
energy
good energy all right what do you got
she's got 820 but who's counting so um
first of all food prices have been on
the rise in the past few months and rice
uh is about to hit it's been creeping up
for the fifth straight month to reach a
12-month high
um and yeah no it's all food prices are
screwed everything well so when the
supply chain gets disrupted in any form
or factor so there's a couple of things
that go to play here the first is uh
take the one that wants to point to
everyone says oh the virus the virus
drivers yes if you send people to sit at
home and you don't let them go to work
there's a slowdown of velocity of money
there's companies that get disrupted
there's all kinds of things that have to
get work through the system and it can
take a year two years three years to get
work through so that definitely has some
impact on the supply chain if you
remember there were ships all waiting
off of the ports there's all these
issues the second thing that occurs is
that when you give out free money to
people 1200 stimulus and many other uh
programs like that their demand explodes
when demand explodes they start to pull
on the supply chains they give me give
me give me and the supply chain is like
[ __ ] we just hit all these obstacles and
now people want more so we've got to
accelerate a bunch of issues it causes
more congestion more issues in the
supply chain the third thing is you then
get uh all sorts of geopolitical
uncertainty around the conflict of
russia and ukraine russia invading
ukraine not good a lot of wheat comes
from there natural gas oil etc and so as
you work your way through this system
what you come to find is that there's
other issues from the geopolitical
conflict so you start to add this all up
and you're like man this is not good
layer in undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy and you get what we have
now which is food at home
food at home the cost has risen 11.9
over the last 12 months wow the cost to
eat at home has risen 12
unsustainable for average american
family why do they say food at home and
not like food at the grocery store
because they have food at home and they
have uh the cost of food out of the home
they break it down into things like yeah
but to get the food in the home you got
to go to the grocery store maybe
i don't know i go to the bodega
you do not come on
next um
all right so coinbase shares are down
because everything is bitcoin bitcoin is
now trading at its lowest level since
december 2020 below 24 000
more than 200 billion has been wiped
out of the crypto market
i'm not gonna say too much but what i am
gonna say
right now
right now
is where legends and fortunes are made
there's a lot of people
who when the price goes down of any
asset real estate stocks whatever
they get real scared nervous they made
undisciplined decisions etc
right now is when legends and fortunes
get made it's been true for decades in
the stock market it's been true for
decades in real estate it's also been
true for years
in the bitcoin market
in 2018
on multiple occasions i went on
television and they were oh it's going
it's good and they're freaking out
is that 3 500 3200 whatever it was
and then you zoom out a number of years
and i tend to think that uh michael
saylor's general sentiment forget for a
second the numbers but his general
sentiment if it's not going to zero it's
going higher okay and what ultimately
occurs is that people have to be able to
separate price and value that's what i
wrote about this morning is price is the
thing that trades every day and that is
based on supply and demand in the moment
so if more people want to sell than buy
price goes down that's true stocks real
estate bitcoin whatever but the value is
over a long period of time what is the
actual value of this thing and when i
look this weekend i went and did a huge
dive i went and i reevaluated the entire
investment thesis is an open source
decentralized digital currency with a
programmatic monetary policy and a
finite supply is that still valuable in
the world how could i think about how
valuable it would be i looked at all the
underlying fundamentals hash rate fees
per transaction the number of
transactions the wallets on chain uh the
lightning network short-term holders
long-term holders everything i went and
looked at all of it
and i came to the conclusion that there
is a divergence between value and price
right now which is at the same time that
price is dropping i think you said it's
the lowest it's been since december of
2020.
at the exact same time
the underlying fundamentals hash rate
all-time high bitcoin wallet addresses
with .01 bitcoin point one bitcoin or
one bitcoin all hitting all-time highs
lightning network capacity hitting
all-time highs all these different
things
it's two different stories and so you
ultimately have to ask for if you're a
trader
then you're looking at short-term price
movements you're trying to figure that
out if you're a long-term holder if you
if you have the warren buffett mentality
i'm gonna buy great assets and hold them
forever which is what i try to do
then what you have to be able to do is
you have to always look at the value of
something and the more that there's a
divergence between price and value then
the more excited you should get about
buying it when there's a big divergence
now you could be wrong and that's
ultimately where risk isn't introduced
and that's ultimately where risk return
is derived from
oh man
yeah you don't like when the price goes
down oh so it's interesting it kind of
like flip-flopped
early on
i was like when the price used to drop
it'd be like hey chill out
and he would be freaking out and now
it's the opposite
i slept eight hours last night i'm
planet is like shook right now as to how
it's just like we've been here before
yeah we've been here before and if you
haven't been here before
understand that the timeless investing
principles
still apply
and so this is true
i have uh
some real estate prices going down yeah
okay i'm a long-term holder i'm not
going to trade
and be careful out there
true very true i like how you say that
too diversify and be careful okay next
thing paypal
[Music]
all right so
do you remember when you called it a
flex when i told the people that when i
interviewed the paypal ceo dan shulman
he told me that he was invested
personally in bitcoin yep okay now he
was interviewed
at consensus 2022 and he said that
paypal's move this week to allow
customers to transfer crypto out of
paypal's cryptocurrency wallet
sorry cryptocurrency walled garden to
external wallets is the opening step
from a fiat oriented world to a digital
currency one so this is how dan shulman
is envisioning the future he said we
will instantaneously take your crypto
and translate it into fiat and you you
will be able to use that in any of our
35 million merchant accounts so we're
trying to add functionality but what we
just did with transfers is kind of like
the opening step is you might think
about us moving from a fiat world to a
digital currency basically you have to
have interoperability you have to be
able to go from digital to fiat fiat to
digital back and forth that's what they
want to be able to try as a digital
currency of course anyone who works in
payments at this point i think they know
that that's going to happen
their ability to withdraw is pretty
important though now that they have that
functionality because there are some
people who say hey i want to actually
receive
bitcoin but i don't want to leave it on
some sort of infrastructure i want to
pull it off a good example right is um
celsius which i know everyone is talking
about online i don't have any more
information than anyone else so i'm just
going off of what i publicly see and
that platform uh last night froze the
ability to move between accounts and
also withdraw now my number one rule
i will not punch down on people i don't
know what's going on but what i do know
is that if you said gun to your head
what do you think is happening my guess
is that there are people who are pulling
assets out and there's a mismatch of
duration they have assets that are
generating yield there's people who are
trying to pull it out and because they
can't match it they've got a pause so
people can't pull out so that they can
then get the funds to then be able to
fund the withdrawals now there's all
kinds of issues this is not something
unique to the crypto market this has
been happening in finance literally for
centuries essentially uh there are uh
all sorts of best practices rules etc as
to how to do this but even hedge funds
do this right there's all sorts of
things there's something called gating
in the hedge fund world where if a bunch
of people say hey this hedge fund was
good now it sucks give me my money back
they have these gating functionality and
they can uh change the gating all that
stuff so i think that what we're
watching play out is that people are
getting a
front row seat to understanding it's
important to understand the risk as to
where you keep your assets and also the
functionality as to when and how you're
able to withdraw or transfer those
assets and in this specific situation
again we don't have all of the
information yet but in this specific
situation it looks like people who have
their funds there cannot get them out
and that cause is a cause for concern i
think that's where you see people saying
hey what the hell is going on over time
we'll find out but
you know at the same time there's been a
lot of people talking about this for a
long time saying hey this specific
platform gets your assets off again
people make their own decisions you have
to live and diet with the risk and uh
that you take and let's see how it plays
out
diversifying be careful out there
okay
uh tick tock water do i even want to
know what this is yes
okay so this is fascinating i love that
i don't know this well so if you were on
tick tock you would know that apparently
there's this water called circle spelled
c-i-r-k-u-l
and their water bottles like went viral
on tick-tock
with their videos eventually racking up
more than a billion views and when the
founder woke up he saw that
visits to his company's website went up
400 percent so he thought it was a
mistake it wasn't a mistake it was tick
tock so circle is basically these like
they're plastic
bottles
hold on so users fill the circle branded
plastic bottles with water insert a
flavor cartridge and set an intensity
dial to customize options ranging from
iced coffee to strawberry lime and the
cart
all this
a starter kit with a bottle and
cartridges sell for about twenty dollars
so is this a science experiment in a
water bottle so anyway the point is the
power of tick tock turn this into a
billion dollar company it is now valued
at a billion dollars well
tick tock is the number one website in
the world is it not i don't know i think
that more people go to went to tick tock
in 2021 than google.com this is crazy
can you imagine that yeah it's marketing
now i'm still trying to figure out the
science experiment that's happening
inside of the waterfall it's just like a
fl i feel like this has been around
forever i don't know why this is that
innovative but people seem to love it i
don't know anything about that
what do you mean you wouldn't want to
put like little strawberries in a
cartridge no i want my i want the real
iced coffee
i don't want the water flavored stuff
what do you think we're american coffee
drinkers oh my god do you remember that
there's a video that a bunch of our
friends were all sending around and it's
like a european pretending to be an
american for the day and he basically
he he jumps out of bed at like 6 a.m he
goes oh my god i have to go and i have
to get my coffee and then he basically
pours a little bit of coffee and then a
bunch of water then he sits down at his
computer and he's like i have to work
and he's like now i have to go to work
and he picks up his computer and he runs
to work and he's like working and he
goes now i have to leave the office and
go home and work more he takes his
computer and he runs home and he's doing
more work he goes now i have to go to
sleep and then he like goes to sleep
with his computer like on his chest and
then he wakes back up he does it all
over again the next day the whole point
is like no but i thought the coffee was
like basically like a plant uh yeah it's
nonsense no nevermind okay what's going
on new york city so new york city
this is interesting so it says that new
york city had one of the largest
declines in the first stage of the
pandemic and one of the fastest rebounds
a lot of people are moving back into
manhattan
more so than before the pandemic do you
buy that well more people are moving in
because it's a base effect right of like
there's so much open inventory that uh
more people i would expect more people
to move back in uh than before the
pandemic god i wish but it's still a net
loss of population
right but the chart goes like this of
course it basically there was a certain
number of people growing it dropped
significantly right because of the
pandemic people leaving it was a net
loss and it's starting to recover but it
still hasn't recovered back above the
pre-pandemic levels of population and so
this is this is new york city this is
what we call manipulating data they're
trying to tell a good story i don't know
they are net losers of the pandemic
so are we do face a tough road ahead
with overall population declining low
office return figures threatening
business survival and fear of crime oh
god
so are
california california and new york are
not losers of the pandemic so do we who
is moving back into manhattan young
people young people
if you're 21 years old right now yeah
and you just got you're graduating with
may yeah you just graduated i would have
been doing that oh part of your face off
cheap rent go explo experience new york
city well the
median rent in uh new york city
manhattan i think is four thousand
dollars now so it's not so much cheap it
was cheap six months ago uh as they had
the supply demand imbalance but uh it's
pretty crazy um yeah all right well that
is it for today one last point i just
got confirmation that ftx said uh quote
they're gonna get mad at this but
whatever the exact email reads we didn't
yet meaning they did not yet pick the
two people so there's still time uh i
plan to choose winners the end of day
or tomorrow am thanks so if you have not
yet gone there is still a chance they're
gonna pick two people those two people
are each gonna get five thousand dollars
all you have to do is go sign up for an
account and they'll take care of you so
i appreciate all of you thank you very
much paulina hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time